okay it's uh I guess it's as good a time
as ever to have this conversation if not
now when right and I know that there's
people in my audience who aren't going
to like this
and they're going to be mad at me and
they're going to disagree and they're
going to dislike the video and they're
going to unsubscribe and a few even the
really special ones will even say
anti-semitic things and will say I'm a
bad person and I'm Michelle but I can't
care about that anymore you know I do
stories as I see them you guys have seen
this throughout the election cycle
sometimes we lose 500 subscribers
sometimes we gain 500 who knows I don't
care it's too serious and so we have to
do it
vote blue no matter who here we go now
is not the same as vote Biden over Trump
all right
let's think this through we've got to
understand this before things swirl out
of control there is a very reasonable
debate to be had about Joe Biden's
policies when Joe Biden says he supports
the green New Deal as a framework what
does that mean versus saying he would
push for specifically the green New Deal
that's a debate that's a great debate to
have but we can't equate vote blue no
matter who to sang I believe Biden would
be better than Trump specifically and
there are many supporters who have been
correctly tweeting me I want to be very
clear you guys are right when you say
David vote blue no matter who
relinquishes agency it says to the DNC
you don't have to earn my vote because
I'm voting blue no matter who I'm gonna
vote for whoever has a D next to their
name no matter who they are or what
their platform is that's absolutely
correct that being said that's not what
I or many others are advocating for I
have never said vote blue no matter who
and in fact I've said quite the opposite
all along I've said I evaluate
candidates and decide who's better it's
not a party analysis and then I say do I
prefer this person to Donald Trump or do
I prefer Donald Trump vote blue
no matter who would be saying I'm not
evaluating candidates I'm merely going
to vote based on whether someone is a
Democrat that's not what I do
Biden is better than Trump on a number
of different issues I've talked about a
lot of them and of course all of these
are up for debate on judges including
the Supreme Court
I don't want Trump choosing Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's replacement I want Biden
choosing Ruth Bader Ginsburg replacement
if you would prefer it be Bernie great
that's not the choice the choice is
Biden or Trump and I prefer Biden on
climate Biden supports the green new
deal as a framework Trump doesn't Trump
thinks climate changes of hoax created
by the Chinese Biden's better on that
taxes is Biden's tax plan as progressive
as Bernie's know is Biden's tax plan
better than Trump's yes on health care
is Biden's tax plan the progressive gold
standard no not even close is it way
better than what Trump tried to do a
couple of years ago of course it is on
diplomacy is Biden an embarrassment
around the world the way Trump is no you
might not like the things Biden will do
with his diplomatic skills and with his
experience but there's no question that
it's better than Trump so back when it
was Bernie and Warren and Amy and Pete
and Biden at that point when there were
five possible candidates who could win
it still wasn't vote blue no matter who
it was when I look at these five any of
these five individuals would be better
than Donald Trump and I would vote for
any of them when it was down to Bernie
and Biden as the last two contenders I
still wasn't vote blue no matter who I'm
not even a Democrat remember it was
either of these two specific people
Bernie or Biden would be better than
Trump and likewise at this point this is
not vote blue no matter who for me it's
given the choices we now have either
Donald Trump will be reelected in
November or Joe Biden will be elected
and Donald Trump will be removed that is
the choice I am making and why I will be
voting for Joe Biden and you know if
the language continues to be arguing
about the principle of vote blue no
matter who we're missing the forest for
the trees
the debate over vote blue no matter who
is a principle is a valid debate and
that's not the debate that we are having
right now in terms of whether to choose
Biden specifically over Donald Trump now
you might prefer Trump to Biden by all
means then vote for Trump or stay home
or write someone in or whatever but
let's not live in this fantasy world
where we're pretending that this is
about the principle of if the DNC
doesn't earn my vote then they don't
deserve it well has Trump earned what is
de facto your support if you choose to
stay home or write someone in because
the idea that it's neutral to vote for
neither of them is one of the falsest
notions that we've been trying to dispel
for years on the program so if you're
okay with your actions
helping Trump get reelected then do
whatever you want I'm not going to fight
with people I'm not going to attack
people I understand that there are many
people who if it's not going to be
Bernie would rather it be Trump than
Biden either because they think that
it's sending a message to the DNC or
they have a burn it all down to build a
backup mentality or they want to punish
it that's fine that's fine but let's
just be honest that that's what you're
doing if that is what you were going to
do I won't argue with you on principle
as long as you're honest and take
responsibility for what it is that
you're doing I just don't want people to
mistake vote blue no matter who with
saying the options are Biden and Trump
and I prefer Biden to trump switch their
party affiliations
tell me Biden's the Republican and
Trump's the Democrat Biden still better
that's the reality let's not mistake a
debate over Trump versus Biden with a
debate over the idea of vote blue no
matter who because that's not going to
get us very far if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps
called blink Asst blink Isleta consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst blink East
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video